- You're the number one
Madden live player in the world?
That can't be real.
- No, it's real.
- That means you play all day.
- That means
that I play all day.
(group laughter)
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Footsteps" by Fiifi Jr.)
- [Gary] You just ate?
Good, man.
What's going on?
No, no, no, I'm good.
Sit. How you doing?
- I'm doing, I'm trying not
to, I don't fuckin' complain.
- No reason to, right?
- You know what?
When you're young you have stuff
to complain about 'cause you got
it all figured out life.
Once you get close to 40 years
old it's like fuck and your
friends start dying of
natural causes and shit.
Like I had a friend, 40 years
old died in his fucking sleep.
In shape, buff as shit, never
smoked or drink in his life,
eats fucking, you know, like
salmon and vegetables and shit
and he just fucking died, man.
- You know my friend
Dustin who's coming by?
You guys know who
Howard Bingham is?
- Yeah.
- Famous photographer.
- So, Howard
Bingham's son, Dustin,
I went to college with.
He's one of my best friends,
coming by and his brother,
Daymond, who did the Ali movie
with Will Smith passed way in
his sleep. It's crazy.
Ali died, Daymond died and
Howard Bingham died as you might
of saw all within like a year.
It all fucking sucks.
- So again, so getting
back to what we're saying--
- Yeah.
- ain't gonna complain.
- Yeah, man.
- You wake up, you're alive.
I wouldn't give a
fuck if you were a bum.
Like you wake up you're alive
and not in prison for the
rest of your life
like you have options.
- 400 trillion to 1.
You know that's my...
I talk about it everyday.
- Yeah.
- When I think about
the fact that my dad coulda,
you know, decide to take a shit
and do you know how hard it is
to become a human?
- [The Game] Exactly, yeah.
- 400 trillion to 1.
Like there's no math.
Like you could win 98 NBA
championships in a row more
likely than being a human being.
- [The Game] Crazy.
- So that's, it's
perspective once you get there.
So what's going on?
So I'm super pumped you're here.
I'm a fan of your work.
What's, give me some context.
Yep, yep, I'm aware.
Yep, yep.
- [Man] I saw Game last
week when he did a show here.
(inaudible) A big
industry show which is a--
- Yep, yep I saw.
- [Man] We did a
walkthrough there,
I asked him if he had known you.
- He said no.
- [Man] Sent him some links.
- Oh you did?
- [Man] I figured you knew.
- I generally don't
mainly think people do.
- [Man] (inaudible) running
through the street people trying
to talk to him.
- Course.
- [Man] You know this guy.
- Yeah, of course.
Yeah, send it, got it. Yep.
And how long have
you guys been jamming?
("Footsteps" by Fiifi Jr.)
- [Man] The NFL thing is insane.
- We had--
- [Man] Number
fucking five on video games,
like, Madden or something.
- I'm number one actually.
- [Man] Is that real?
- Yeah, it's real.
- You're the number one
Madden live player in the world?
That can't be real.
- No, it's real.
- That means you play all day.
- That means
that I play all day.
(group laughter)
- My man. There's
just no other way.
- It's true.
- Like straight,
without bullshit,
they have, I haven't
played Madden in a while.
Like when we go on to Xbox or
whatever like they have the
rankings, right?
- I'm number one on
every Xbox that you can
fucking see in the world.
- That's, I believe you.
- [DRock] That's amazing.
- Well I don't give
a fuck if you don't.
I'm still gonna beat you.
(group laughter)
I'm there.
- That's crazy.
- Yeah, and if you think
about it's how I got my name.
Like I fucking grew up playing
video games and my grandmother's
from Texas and she's old
Southern and she would just be
like this fucking
kid is game for anything.
Game this, game that and
so that's how I got my name.
So before I became a rapper--
- Holy shit.
- my name was just game, my
nickname was just game as a
child growing up.
- I didn't know that.
- So when it became, it's funny
because when I signed to Dr. Dre
that wasn't my rap name.
- [Gary] What was it?
- It was like fucking,
what the fuck was it?
(Gary laughs) Oh,
it was MC Compton.
- [Gary] MC Compton.
- MC Compton and I had Mike
Rockwell who everybody laughs at
when he asks me and I tell them
'cause I rocked the mic well and
my sister's like
that's fucking weak.
(group laughter)
And so my younger
sister who's now 27,
she was, back then
she was fucking 17,
she was like why don't you
just be your
regular name, stupid.
And I'm like what?
She's like game.
And add like mister or a
doctor or a T-H-E like a the.
And I was like the game, bitch.
- [Gary] I love that story.
- And then so when I actually
went to the studio to meet Dre
and Nate too and 50 and
all in the studio,--
- [Gary] Yep, yep.
- He's like what's your name.
I was just like, and I was
thinking it and I wanted to say
MC Compton but
I'm like The Game.
He's like it's fucking dope.
Welcome to aftermath.
I'm like fuck!
(group laughter)
Yeah, man. That's how it is.
- [Gary] That's good shit.
- So Game's been with
me all the time so--
- That's crazy.
- I've bene playing video
games is since Nintendo.
- So wait a minute.
Let's take a step back.
Like just on another kick.
How do you
thinking about e-sports?
Are you thinking
about that at all?
Have you opened up
your eyes to that world?
- I'm just not really getting
off of my console and starting
to branch out and I just got
into PC gaming and in e-sports.
My boy, who's like number
seven at Madden put me on it.
So I'm like
starting to figure it out.
'Cause that fucking world--
- Game, seriously
on a very serious,
I know we've been through this.
- Yeah.
- You're literally the
number one player on Madden.
- Number one on
Madden in the world.
This world.
- [Phil] This world.
(laughs)
- That's the best.
The current one, the
one that's out right now?
'17.
- '17.
- And what did you
end up being on '16?
- On '16 I was number one.
(group laughter)
- Shit is great.
- Yeah, it's crazy.
- You're just
unstoppable in Madden.
- I'm fucking amazing at Madden.
- What about Live?
- I don't play Live, I play 2K.
- Okay and?
- And this year I haven't
played any head to head.
- Yep.
- I've been playing my players.
That's the biggest thing on 2K.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't know if you know about
that but I was number one since
2011 on 2K, too.
- Is it just sports
games that you're that dominate
or shooter games?
- No, no, no.
The first Modern Warfare
I was number one on COD 2.
- Have you ever been
number two on anything?
- Halo.
- Yeah!
(group laughter)
- E-sports is gonna be, e-sports
is gonna be the number three
sport in America in 10 years.
- [The Game] Yeah.
- E-sports, e-sports, do
you have a Twitch channel?
- I have a Twitch channel,
I got fucking
locked out of it somehow.
Stream to like 100,000 but
it was the beginning stages.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Everybody wants to
watch me fucking play Madden.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Man 2] I want to
see you beat everybody.
- So what happens on XBox--
- [Gary] Who do you play with?
- I play with any team.
- [Gary] Can you start playing
with the Jets a little more,
I need some more wins.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I'm like 40 and 0
with Jets or something.
- [Gary] Yes! My man.
- [The Game] Yeah, I just play
with any team 'cause after a
while you know if you
play, like it gets boring.
- Yeah.
- [The Game] I play with the
49ers and I won so many games
for them it's like I
need to play with other teams.
So currently I've just been
playing with the Chiefs--
- [Gary] Do you do dumb shit
like pull your defensive linemen
off the line?
- I do that.
- [Gary] That's how
I got bad at Madden.
- Yeah.
- I used to be good
at Madden, '93, '94. '95.
- [The Game] Yeah.
- And just amongst my friends.
I got so bored
being good at it
I started
getting into bad habits.
- [The Game] Yeah.
- And then when shit changed and
I got busy I couldn't recover.
Uh-huh.
- [Tyler] Well Vick
changed it for everyone.
- [The Game] Vick--
- And everyone was
like I'm just fucking gonna
run with my quarterback.
- [The Game] When Vick got
drafted to the fucking Falcons,
Madden changed forever.
- [Tyler] For year they
came out with the QB cone.
(crosstalk)
- Or the quarterbacks just
weren't fucking fast as Vick
- Uh-huh.
Yeah Warren Moon
wasn't running by anybody.
- No, he's fucking slow as shit.
Randal Cunningham.
- Cunningham was fast.
- Yeah but on the
game he's like an 8.
- Yeah, yeah on the game.
- Michael Vick
came on with 96 speed.
No one fucking passed the ball.
Like it was just
fucking crazy, man.
Yeah, and I'm still
number one after that.
(group laughter)
- That's cool.
Makes sense.
I'm glad you did that.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Yeah, listen,
from my standpoint,
open for business.
It sounds like you got a
good understanding for me.
I prefer leverage.
- [The Game] Right.
- I'm so insular.
I'm gonna get mine
regardless of what anybody does.
So my basic
thesis is how do I give?
How do I give?
And give without expectations
just give, give, give.
That's where all
the leverage comes from.
- [The Game] Right.
- So, you know, if you want to
get some more established LPs
for the fund, if you want
to figure out something that
VaynerMedia's doing right.
If you want to come
to New York and see it.
If you hear me say something
about Facebook video or
influencer marketing.
- [Man] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Anyway I can be a
help, I'm interested.
You know, my main thing with the
young up and coming guys from
Atlanta and shit like
that from the music standpoint,
just for context, is I'm just
trying to hack culture 24/7/365.
It's just hacking culture.
If you can, and you know, MC
Compton paid attention to more
people than The Game when he's
at that point of the career.
Once more shit comes to you,
it's just supply and demand.
So I just want to try to
evaluate people on the come up,
bring them more value.
Know that 80% of them
aren't gonna get through.
But the 20% that do are a net
positive and I'm still not gonna
ask them for anything
but it's nice to have.
That's basically my thesis.
It's a great thesis.
It's the tried and true are
you doing this for 40 years?
I'm not ever gonna be number on
on Madden but I'm gonna buy the
New York Jets and
win a fucking Super Bowl.
- [Man] Yeah, I believe you.
Everyone believes you.
- [The Game] I like
the way you fucking think.
I'll buy the
fucking Rams, play you guys.
(group laughter)
Fuck it,
who you gonna buy?
(group laughter)
Doesn't it look like the Raiders
are gonna get to Vegas.
- [The Game] Yeah.
- Looks like that shit--
- [Man 2] Chargers here.
- Done.
- [The Game] Done.
- Done. Done.
- [The Game] You know what's
crazy is what the fuck are they
gonna do about
the same color scheme?
I thought about your mind state
I thought about starting some
shit where I'm me
personally make the Chargers
change their colors.
- By the way, do that tomorrow.
- Change your colors or
get the fuck out of here.
- What's going
on with your social?
("Footsteps" by Fiifi Jr.)
Alright, man.
Hey.
- Appreciate it.
- Thank you.
Continued success.
- Appreciate you taking my time.
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
Game, what's your number?
Tell these
characters about the Ida.
Tell them how really--
- Well, I already told them
that every November right before
Thanksgiving--
- [Gary] Oh this is good.
I've never said this publicly.
- Right before Thanksgiving,
Gary was like fuck it
I got to go.
Like what are you doing?
I got to go work in the shop.
Busiest time of the month.
I'm like finals.
Fuck finals.
School's more important, I
mean the work's more important.
I got to go to the shop.
I'm like alright,
he's never coming back.
- [Gary] You ready for this?
I left so, no, no
actually you know what
the version of that is?
I left so early
freshman year, so early,
when I came to campus sophomore
year that's what you're
referring to.
- Yeah.
- I got out of the car.
I saw them sitting on a stoop
drinking fucking Saint Ives.
They looked at me
like I was a ghost.
They were like we didn't
think you were coming back.
'Cause there's no texting.
We didn't keep in touch.
See ya.
Four months later.
There was a suite called 301,
that's where we all friends.
- It was five rooms, the two
outside rooms had four men to it
and then the three
inside had two a piece.
And I was the only one that
wasn't actually in the dorm.
- But he was part of our crew.
- When we come in there, at
one point Gary set up a bar.
Bring up all the alcohol.
Set up a bar,
actually like functioning bar.
Drunk Ass Pete we
used to call him Dap.
- Drunk Ass Pete.
Dap, he had a dap hat.
- He would sit
there and drink all day.
- Like he was Norm.
He'd be like Gary,
hit me for another one.
I'm like alright.
- I mean the guy,
what was he downing?
- Jack Daniels.
- What was the other dude?
- Oh, his buddy from Jersey.
- Oh, what was his name?
- Tom?
- They would cling,
what was it? A pint?
A pint and just down them.
- Remember the time he funneled
an entire 750 of Jack Daniels?
And passed out
eight seconds later.
- Drunk Ass Pete.
- Funneled Jack Daniels.
- Those were good times, man.
- Those were very good times.
("Footsteps" by Fiifi Jr.)
Guys, I'm telling
you if I was doing
DailyVee back then we
would watch that like...
- Yeah. Legendary.
- And all this flip
shit, tell them about
the Spice Girls dolls.
Remember that shit
and we used to go on to?
- Oh, he actually got me doing.
We got some store line ups.
We used to go, get
up early in the morning,
go hit Toys 'R Us, Gary try
to bribe the guy in the back.
- I didn't try.
I had him on payroll.
There was no trying.
- Hot Wheels or whatever it was.
- I would pay a guy $20 a week,
he would open up the toys and
the expensive ones,
he'd keep in the back,
I'd come through
and I'd get 'em all.
- Yeah, everything. Yep.
- People think this is new shit.
This is old school stuff.
- What was it?
Giz toys.
- Mhmmm.
- Giz toys.
- I forgot that was the
name of the eBay account.
- Giz toys.
- Holy shit.
Madden, you dominated
Madden except for Stoker's run.
- Don Maynard, hall of famer.
- Those Jets, you know what if
you've seen my keynote when
I talk about
playing Madden '95 I was
with Don Maynard, hall of famer.
That was the
only time I was good.
When the '69
Jets were introduced.
I was too prideful and I was
like can't let these guys lose.
I remember I beat Chief.
Remember Chief?
The Indian kid.
I beat him like 68 to nothing.
How 'bout this trip?
- Got to trade it.
- Uh-huh.
- Big time.
- You know what's funny?
I really need to get some
stories from you guys 'cause
I forget things like--
- You forget things?
- No, I remember a
lot of things but you.
- Forget nothing.
- That's true,
I remember everything.
(group laughter)
I remember when you
guys all went to UConn
and didn't take me.
- Oh yeah, well that was,
that was at Mike's house, right?
- Mhmmm.
- Yep, yep.
Well what about,
you weren't old enough.
- I was too high energy.
Oh, that was devastating.
- Yeah.
- Me and Moose,
we were both 21 now.
His 21st birthday, you've
maybe actually all three of you,
that story when I lost all my
money in Vegas but then I hit
the straight,--
- Walking out the door.
- [Phil] I don't know that one.
- You don't know the story that
we went for his 21st birthday,
his 21st birthday in
Las Vegas, in Las Vegas.
I get there four hours early.
I come with $3,000.
Everybody else comes,
Mis comes with $47.
We're in Las Vegas
for four days,
no, no, no, no.
Ready for this?
Vegas for four days,
L.A. for three days,
that man comes with
$47 and don't laugh 'cause
that's what he had.
We were, it was ghetto, man.
Anyway, I get there and
I fucking start gambling.
And I'm losing like I never,
just losing and now I'm scared
'cause I'm like fuck.
I know I kind of have
to help everybody else
get through this week.
So I'm feeling a
little bit of responsibility.
So like I'm down to $1500.
I'm like okay, I'm gonna
starting betting 100 at a time.
I got to get back up.
Lose.
And I've got $200.
In four hours I lose $2800.
- [Tyler] They hadn't
arrived yet, right?
- They hadn't arrived.
Then they get there.
They kind of come in.
They're like, "Hey!"
They see me and I like white.
- Pressed.
- I'm already the most
white guy with the crew.
Now I'm real white, right?
They were like what?
So I'm depressed.
They're going to get settled.
They're like pissed at me.
They thought I was joking.
I'm like I lost my money.
They're like get
the fuck out of here.
Duh-duh, I'm like fuck.
So I walk around--
- '95?
- No, no, way better.
I don't know if,
you'll remember in a minute.
I hear commotion.
I need to clear my head.
I look over, there's
some Asian dude going nuts.
Nuts, so I look he got four
queens in Caribbean Poker won
like a $1,000 and
he gets up and leaves.
And there's this
family, country family,
like five characters.
Like mom, dad, the kids
and they got real
thick Nebraska accents.
And I'm like, "Can I sit down?"
'Cause it's like $10 a hand.
They're like sure.
They're super fun.
Third hand, third hand and the
way I play Caribbean Poker is
I keep four cards
down, I keep one down.
- [DRock] Don't look at it.
- Yeah, I don't look at it.
So I pull up the
four and I'm like three,
five, six, seven.
All hearts.
And now I'm like,
you know who I am.
Showing, I'm like guys,
if I have a four of hearts,
no thought, I'm thinking,
I got a straight flush.
Four of hearts.
- [DRock] No.
- $44,000 is the whole
pot for royal flush so
I got 10%, $4,400, one hand.
I have to fill
out the tax thing.
I sent a check home for $2,000.
- I wasn't
talking about that time.
I was talking about when we were
walking out the casino and you
put it on five on
the roulette table.
- Yes, yes. You
know that's our move.
- Bet's on five.
- Bang, $3500.
- Fuck this guy.
Every one else is
rolling and we're like
lost our ass and this guy.
- You know what I remember about
that trip more than anything?
The number one thing I remember,
not Glenn jumping over the
escalator trying to get
girls going the other way.
Not that, not all that.
Bone Thugs and 2Pac's song just
came out and we listened to it
on the drive from Vegas to L.A.
That's the number
on thing I remember.
Oh, before I go you
got to hear about Coach K.
No internet so we
would just go to the mall,
I'd be like, I'd be sitting
there and if it got boring
enough I'd be like,
"Hey let's go to the mall
and I'll buy a video game."
Everyone's like okay.
Literally that's what happened.
Get in Moose's fucking hoopdy.
He'd be playing fucking Pimp C
or some shit that nobody knew
what the fuck.
- Classics.
Did he?
We go to the mall and it would
be like so fun 'cause that's how
we found out about Playstation.
- Yep.
- No internet.
No internet.
- [Phil] Yeah, yeah.
- We get back sophomore
year we go let's go do
what we did last year.
It was first day so I
was coming back with bank.
And I was like
let's go to the mall.
- Pay cash every year?
- No, I only pay
cash for everything.
- Rolls up to
school and pays cash.
- Tuition.
(group laughter)
You know how weird that is?
- They're probably
thinking this guy is a
drug dealer or something.
- Yeah, that's how
Sasha Vaynerchuk did it.
So anyway, fucking we
went to the mall to buy
a new Genesis game.
I will never
forget this actually.
'Cause you, we
were so into video,
we were like as soon as we
walked in into KB Toy Store it
had a big display.
- KB.
KB Toys and we were
like what the fuck is that?
- Yep.
- And I'll never
forget it we're like,
it was so expensive.
It seemed like so much money and
we're like and they were like do
you want to see a demo of
Battle Arena
Toshendo or whatever, right?
Battle Arena Toshendo
came out with it, right?
It was a fighting game.
I'm almost sure it's
Battle Arena Toshendo or
something like that.
Yeah, and we're like
okay and the shit was like,
we didn't even understand.
We were like CDs?
- [Phil] Yeah.
- We didn't know.
So I brought it
back, we bought it.
I wasn't gonna buy it.
It was real money,
I was there ready for $40,
it was $230. You had
to get another game.
This is the single reason.
He's like come on,
come on, come on.
- It was hard for
him to tell me and Moose no.
- Yeah, you guys teamed up.
Not those two.
So I bought it, we get back
and like in five minutes there's
like 10 minutes the word on
campus everybody's in our dorm
like what the fuck is this?
- Yeah.
- It was crazy.
- I was skree.
- That's what he called it.
I love it, man.
I love you.
Come watch this
if you got a minute.
Yeah, those are
some good stories.
What a great day.
Got to spend time with the
number one player on Madden and
the man that was the number
one player at Mount Ida College.
Love it.
- ♫ Bow down,
confess all your sins.
The internet wins
when Beyonce has twins,
Thank Jesus above for this
glorious day and I'm gonna slap
you in the face if
you don't praise the Bey.
Oh, I,
I'm gonna
slap you in your face.